[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, you'll see
how you can get
TensorBoard working
with Keras-based
TensorFlow code.
In this example, I'm using
the Fashion MNIST dataset
to do some basic
computer vision, where
I can train a Keras
neural network to classify
items of clothing.
It's set to train
for five epochs,
and you can see the
progress, including
the loss and the accuracy,
in the output window.
We can see that it
finishes training
with an accuracy of
about 86%, and we
output some sample predictions.
But how do we visualize
this with TensorBoard?
Let's start by importing
the time library
and TensorBoard itself.
It can be found in
tensorflow.pytho
n.kera.callbacks.
Next, after the
model is defined,
we want to instantiate
TensorBoard.
Note that we specify
a log directory
where stuff will get written.
Finally, as the
model is training
in the model.fit
function, we need
to tell Keras to call
back to TensorBoard.
We simply do this by specifying
the callback's parameter
and tell it to use whatever we
call the TensorBoard instance.
In this case, it's all
lowercase tensorboard.
Now, in your terminal, you
can execute the TensorBoard
command, pointing
at the log directory
that you just specified.
You'll see that it
executes, and it gives me
a TensorBoard at HTTP
Machine Name colon 6,006.
Now, if I retrain
again, when it's done,
I can take a look
in TensorBoard.
TensorBoard will launch, and I
can start investigating things
like the loss and the accuracy.
I can also look
at the graph that
was built for the training.
And that's just how to
get it up and running.
There's lots of great things
that you can do further with
TensorBoard, and
you can see them
at tensorflow.org/tensorboard.
To learn more about TensorFlow,
visit tensorflow.org.
For more videos
about TensorFlow,
click the Subscribe
button, and if you've
any questions about this
video, please leave them
in the comments below.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]